I'm going to ask my co-workers what
celebrity their dad looks like my dad I
love you reminds me of Shrek
oh really funny and he also lost track I
trust me it is a good thing that I say
this to him love you Dad Winslow from
from Family Matters literally my dad
looks like my television dad in the 90s
Bob from Bob's Burgers my dad literally
looks exactly like him people used to
say that my dad looked like Jackie Chan
I would say Jackie Chan mixed with
George Lopez Clint Eastwood
I don't know if that's a compliment or
Not Sorry dad my dad looks most like you
know I would say the flash because he's
never really there everyone says my dad
looks like Michael Kane Brian Cranston I
think we always said that my dad was the
real life Breaking Bad El Don Walter
White he's a Mexican dad my dad looks
like a taller version of Steve Zahn Tony
Young Vin Diesel yes